you when you go to the conbini right
yeah what's the top three what's the
topic food items that you get
depends on the kombini yeah i always get
i always get yeah it depends on the
konbini but say if it's family mob
yeah yeah i always get the [ __ ] tuna
bread
you know the bread oh the like the long
boy yeah yeah that shit's good
long boy tuna bread that [ __ ] always
because okay anything with mayo in here
yeah
in japan is so much better yeah so like
the chicken
tuna bread with the mayonnaise someone
who hates mayo i gotta admit
like japan japan is the only place
where i can kind of be okay with it
i will never eat mayo by itself but when
it's in like a
nice potato salad or something yeah i i
[ __ ] with that i thought
that egg sandwiches were the most
depressing [ __ ] thing in the world i
agree
in the uk they're like this white mush
that looks disgusting it smells
vile it's just gross and then you have
it in japan it's like this this yellow
bright color it's inviting it's like oh
eat me
and i was like you know what i just made
me i just might
and i had it i had it i had it
and my mind was blown and i i cannot
stop eating the egg sandwiches here man
the egg sandwiches
i can never eat an egg sandwich anywhere
else now because i'm going to be
thinking japan japan has ruined eggs for
me
eggs and mayo are just god yeah because
like i
remember the concept of just going to my
first like yakiniku place
and just having the dips like for some
like dipping sauce
in like yakiniku which is how do i
explain yakiniku it's just like
a grilled meat yeah basically it's like
korean barbie how do i explain it
it's just me it's like korean barbecue
but replace korean with japanese yeah
and it's on like a skewer basically
so for some for some for some dishes
they give you just like an
egg as a dipping sauce like the egg yolk
a raw egg yolk
which firstly the concept of eating raw
eggs was
really really weird for me yeah until i
tried it for the first time
and raw egg here tastes [ __ ] great
yeah oh yeah and it's
safe i think the producer is obsessed
with eggs
yeah it's it's completely that you can't
get salmonella here from the eggs yeah
pretty impossible yeah when i did uh one
of my videos
i like drank a bunch of egg and all the
comments were like
oh my god connor you're gonna die you're
gonna get salmonella you dumb [ __ ]
i know more i got told eggs give
salmonella and i was like
reverse uno card in this yeah hit me up
with that you can't you can't it's like
i don't think it's a hundred percent
unlikely yeah
i have heard of a couple it's worth the
risk it's worth it i've heard of a
couple of my friends get like very
mild salmonella from the eggs here but
it's really really rare like it's it's
not as easy to get salmonella like in
america
it's because i think in uh america and
the uk and most of europe i think we we
wash the eggs
and we get rid of the protective film
yeah the coat and i think it's also
something to do with
how we feed them certain drugs
to like make them agree into diseases
yeah um yeah cause like
what is it uh shabu-shabu and sukiyaki
that's one of my favorites is like yeah
i put you on to that right yeah
that's the best [ __ ] hot pot shabu
shabu is like
they they boil like this meat and veg in
this in this broth and it's kind of weak
it's like ah i don't write shabu-shabu
it's it's like they always advertise
themselves as shabu-shabu places
and then they might have the sukiyaki on
the menu yeah
but they never advertise it's always yo
we got shabu-shabu yeah and it tastes
like [ __ ]
it's like water yeah it's like bath
water i don't know me i feel like i i
still think like the best hot pot for me
is chinese hot pot
chinese hot pot it's like way more
flavorful
and it's like it's a heavyweight have
you had sukiyaki though have you had it
i
have i have yeah okay so sukiyaki if you
don't know home it's
what's the broth that they cook in it
it's like a rich like it's
soy based with like a little bit of like
uh [ __ ] was it it's like uh
dashi yeah it's dashi i don't know how
to explain it it's just really rich
broth and to like mellow it out and give
it this really like enhance the flavors
you dunk it in
like egg yolk yeah and yeah it's like a
raw egg you whip it up
and you dip that [ __ ] in yeah you cook
everything in the broth you
and it's all covered in soy like all the
veggies absorb it you dunk it in the egg
and then you eat it
and it's [ __ ] amazing it's so good
it's so good it's so good
and chinese hot pot is good right but i
think sukiyaki is better yeah chinese
i write chinese hot pot every time i've
had a chinese hot pot i'm like hell yeah
japanese hot pot it's pretty good too
we've had it at our place yeah yeah
we had like uh i don't know which house
we had that on christmas cause connor
didn't want a [ __ ] roast
none of us have an oven what are we
gonna roast gone
how are we gonna [ __ ] roast the
chicken in the tiny little fish grill
yeah
you got like a you get a grill in your
like uh uh stove top right
oven top sorry and you get this grill
for fish
and it's like this wine yeah you have
like it can literally fit just one fish
yeah you want a roasted potato good
[ __ ] luck dude you gotta cut that
[ __ ] you're gonna have to like pan fry
the potato yeah
he's like i want a roast how are we
gonna have a roast car explain the
logistics behind this the logistics gone
i'm bringing it back now i have an oven
and i think yeah
yeah so yeah next time sorry sorry that
we can afford an oven
why would i need an oven when i eat out
every [ __ ] day
you're so lazy why'd you eat out
sometimes i meal i meal prep
meal prep that sounds so [ __ ] lame
yeah a meal prep bro um
i'll make a curry that like for five
days and i'll eat the curry over five
days like a thai curry yeah yeah
that's about it as far as cooking goes
but that's the thing or it's like i feel
japan
i'm pretty sure we touched upon this on
a previous episode but people got so
pissed when we said that they were like
it's not cheaper to eat out if you do
x and x and x and it's like yeah if i
eat pasta and sauce of course it's going
to be cheap yeah yeah but if you want to
have something that tastes
different yes it's going to maybe be
like a honey if you want a different
meal every day
yeah exactly and you can't be [ __ ] to
go shopping every day because the expiry
date on [ __ ] is like
two days to go yeah and more often not
when you buy stuff like it's too much
portions that i can't use like veg here
is normally
portioned for more than one person yeah
it's like family portion yeah so like
i wanted uh like uh what was it like uh
the what's the small onions like the
green onions what are they called
green onions shallots no [ __ ]
shallots i think it's shallots in
america yeah
you spring onion spring onion for us
yeah it's you cannot just get like two
spring onions is
a whole [ __ ] yeah it's either a whole
[ __ ] one or a giant tub of
like cut up ones and i'm talking like
more than any one person could ever use
in a way
like that it's like a tub like this
thick just filled with these cards it's
like i'm not gonna use this i feel bad
because i throw
all of the ingredients away because i
can't use it it's because it like these
cut shallots are used in literally every
year yeah they are they also and like if
i
like get tomatoes they always come in
like packs of like six yeah
tomatoes are [ __ ] big like i don't
need six most of the time yeah
and you know because of how we do like
say we record on tuesdays we're gonna
eat out and then maybe on monday i'm
going to meet someone for a meeting or
maybe i'm
i've got a shoot on thursday so i'm
gonna eat out so it's more like one day
a week i eat in yeah and even then i'll
just go to the conbini get the 500 yen
ramen yeah yeah which is like
you know sure i could make it which is
technically the top tier well yeah
which i could make my own ramen would be
more expensive so it's like yeah of
course some people if you want to be
picky about it yeah you can save money
the same way if you eat pasta in the uk
you'll save a [ __ ] save money
but if you want to like live if you
actually want to like you know enjoy
your food yeah yeah if you want to not
be depressed 24 7 or what you're eating
like yeah
okay yeah yeah because going back to the
conbini thing about
foods that we buy like i i i go less to
the combination
convenient now to get meals i remember
when i first moved here every day i
would like i would
go to get a combination like every
[ __ ] day yeah and like the combini
fried chicken here
is [ __ ] great okay yeah with an
asterisk
family mart fried chicken [ __ ] sucks
okay
it's way too greasy it's it's like a
layer of like fat
you feel like you're eating death yeah
because you're taking a bite
and i see youtubers i think like chris
broad says that his favorites family
mart chicken
and you eat into this thing and it's the
most depressed thing you can eat it's as
depressed as he is
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
you take a bite into this it is pure
water and oil that chicken was was
probably anemic in its real life right
and they pumped that [ __ ] with water and
oil and they're like yeah do it
lawson's fried chicken on the other hand
nah nah nah seven
seven fried chicken fried chicken i
think seven chickens in the middle man
there's lawsons do this like sweet and
and uh
sour i don't know is it oh it's uh salty
and sweet right like teriyaki
fried chicken it's [ __ ] good dude
yeah it's [ __ ] good it hits different
it hits back
you bite into this thing it's fighting
you bro in a good way it's like damn
there's so much flavor in this thing
like
holy [ __ ] i just wanted the fried
chicken no no not a fight okay also
when you first come to japan right yeah
you're like onigiri bro
jelly full donuts immediately yeah cause
it's new
it's exciting it tastes good and then
when i moved here
i was eating it and i'm like this kind
of tastes
boring really boring and then i i
thought who would who would have a
sandwich in japan i don't want a sound
where i get a better sandwich in the uk
yeah and then you you know you start
experimenting a little bit and i had the
egg and
my go-to sandwich combo i cry if this
isn't available in lawson's they have
like a god tier tuna mayo sandwich
yeah and the other one is a uh the egg
one the egg in hand
it's beautiful yeah it's beautiful man i
cry every time yeah that is definitely
my favorite like
sandwich coffee it's so good because you
have the tuna and you're like oh a
little you know a little salty little
fishy
you have the the egg the mayo one you're
like [ __ ] dude this is good yeah yeah
i'm actually the opposite when i
first moved here i'm like why do i [ __ ]
why would i want a [ __ ] onigiri
and now it's just like a very nice
casual snack where like you don't want a
full meal yeah you just wanna get quite
filling though i find
that that's it like you have you have
that as a snack and it fills you up and
you don't need anything else
exactly like for a while i guess yeah
like i always when i
go to the conbini in the morning
sometimes i can't be bothered to like
make a breakfast
yeah so i go to the compete in the
morning and i always get my breakfast
and then some kind of onigiri because i
know the breakfast is gonna fill me up
yeah but then i know a couple of hours
later i'm gonna be feeling a little bit
peckish
and the onigiri is just perfect to fill
in that little spot that creates
my problem with onigiri is sometimes
like it's it's like a coin toss
like you might get one where they're
generous with the fillings yeah
sometimes you bite into that [ __ ] and
there's one shred of tuna in it
and you're like where is the flavor bro
i just ate into seaweed and rice
like there's one piece of tuna with a
slab of mayo on it yeah yeah yeah yeah
it sucks man
if it was consistent maybe i'd like it
but you only eat the tuna
onion no i like the salmon and the
cardro one oh yeah yeah the cardboard
one's fine but
carter is kind of intense so have you
tried like some of the other flavors
like the flavored rice flavors i've had
the
oh you mean like the fried rice yeah
yeah the fried rice ones are fine but
again i'm always thinking like they're
situational for me
i would rather than warm like go back to
this [ __ ]
i want it warm
man i don't know i don't know would you
rather cold rice or a microwave rice
cold well then stop [ __ ] complaining
but but
like i would rather be like freshly yeah